as willie calhoun
will lead things off
calhoun
this hangs up into center field
easy play for kyle lewis the flexons one
two mariners outfield making some
dynamic plays both
defensively and at the plate
two quick outs as connor falefa cuts
through a heater elevated fastball at 91
miles an hour first baseman nate lone
cuts through a good heat 94 from flex
and a couple of punch-outs as he faces
the minimum in the first
allard
10 relief appearances his first start
of the season he's just 23 years old
in the air out to left field that's a
routine play for jason martin and
kellnick retired for the first out of
the inning
now mitch haniger
262
start to the year for hannigan but 13
home runs and he ties into that one
pretty well garcia back through the wall
gets in position leaps and did he get it
he did
adolesce garcia takes another one away
and there are two outs in the inning
what can't he do
we have a tendency to focus on the
offense so what about the defense
getting up over the wall taking one back
and away from mitch haniger one start we
will see
this ball hit well to center field
chases garcia back again near the wall
he'll make the catch and the inning is
done
and adolesce garcia
with two good plays in center field and
we've played a scoreless first tonight
he leads off the second
and lines this into center cal lewis
makes the two string catch
how does joey gallow
have the fourth highest strikeout rate
in baseball and the second highest walk
rate in baseball
the o2
and he gets wrong up on the corner third
strikeout for flexon
a much better command for flexon
flicks this towards the gap hannigar
angling back to flag it down six up six
down chris flexon
i think i think
i wrote down the quote i think 65
pitches should be his max tonight is
what he said i said
is 65 a fair number question mark you
know what
you're right
2-2 and france take strike three call
back-to-back strikeouts for allard here
in the second
and he broke his bat on a weak fly ball
center field but garcia is right there
his third catch of the ball game already
11 pitch second inning for ali no score
he came in on his hands and he fouls it
back holt to strike out victim number
four from chris flexon aggressive with
the cutter that was 90 miles an hour
borderline on the corner
much better command
3-2 to trevino and there's the first
base hit of the ball game jose
is on with two out here in the third
all right
sliced into left kelnick
easy play
and the lone hit of the game so far is
stranded at first base
it was tom murphy leads off the bottom
of the third
as this one will not be robbed it's gone
crushed
tom murphy
not taking this one back it's one
nothing mariners so two and two
nottingham
high fly ball into the corner and it
planks a mile high
and goes beneath the scoreboard
oh back to back jacks and it's two
nothing mariners a 35 ground ball weight
for him which is below league average
well there's one on the ground under
hand to second one on to first double
play and the inning is over
so a couple of home runs for seattle but
allard battles back
the payoff
up the middle late hot mayfield has it
running start crawford double play
inning over
i would also guess that maybe we would
see some action in the bullpen or at
least some of that stretching that you
see you guys know that maybe a phone
call is coming
there you go i believe he did he did and
that strikeout
ends the inning a one two three for
allard
my big pitch right here
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
nottingham
okay
that's a huge out one away back-to-back
really good fastballs from taylor hearn
we saw it 97 this one 96 on the corner
nottingham cannot catch up
pitch on the way and a swing and a miss
he strikes out mayfield back to back
strikeouts
all right it's horn bouncing back
beautifully now on the fifth against a
young star
kellnick pops it up near third base holt
is there and he takes care of it and the
inning is done so great bounce back for
the left-hander taylor hearn he'll take
us to the sixth inning in a two-nothing
game
dialed in tonight
another punch out on the line for chris
flexon he is dazzling tonight in game
one against the rangers against the
rangers if you can work ahead with some
quality strikes which he's been able to
do
you can start to expand the zone i'd say
the second greatest rangers theme sports
jacket
lined down the left field line and into
the corner and that'll be extra bases
for willie calhoun
he'll try for three the throw cut off
and calhoun with a two out triple
[Applause]
ground ball right to nottingham he calls
uh flexson gallops over the bag and that
triple goes no further
that brings a tight run to the plate
here in the seventh
in the form of joey gallo
he goes down on three pitches
two away he was clearly looking for the
heater and flexon wasn't going to give
it to him mayfield will stand in
mayfield a high lift out towards left
center field and short hops off the wall
france is in murphy is chugging home and
jack mayfield puts two more across for
the mariners they lead it four nothing
to the bottom of the seventh chance to
really open this one up now the
dangerous mitch haniger when he hits
this one on the ground and that's up the
middle for a base hit nottingham's in
mayfield being sent to throw the play
and they got him so mayfield gunned down
to win the inning
and this will do it
jp waiting all night for it puts it away
and the mariners shut out the texas
rangers 5-0
to take the first to four